riga capitale de la lettonie une ville
de contrastes où se côtoient les
vestiges de l'époque soviétique et les
nouveaux quartiers depuis l'indépendance
du pays en 1991
de nombreux russophone vivent toujours
en lettonie comme tatiana à 63 ans
c'est le grand jour pour elle elle va
peut-être devenir citoyenne layton ce
n'est pas vraiment bien d'être apatride
être citoyen signifie exister et moi
j'aime la halle et oui asseyez-vous
alors voilà comment va se dérouler la
matinée les candidats vont passer un
test de langue de constitution et
d'histoire layton une épreuve
obligatoire pour changer de statut nous
n'avons pas été autorisés à filmer
l'examen deux heures plus tard tatiana a
le sourire
on a réussi ou a fêté ça en lettonie sur
deux millions d'habitants 12% sont
apatrides c'est russophone se sont
installé durant l'occupation soviétique
et ne sont jamais repartis depuis
l'indépendance une loi les oblige à
parler couramment le letton pour obtenir
la citoyenneté pour les autorités le
langage c'est la base d'une bonne
intégration les éléments clés de
l'intégration c'est le langage c
comprendre les principes de bases d'un
état où vous vivez quelles sont les
valeurs de cet état voilà pourquoi les
gens qui veulent devenir citoyens
doivent suivre cette procédure de
naturalisation
mais la langue c'est aussi l'une des
principales contraintes pour ces
russophone qui vivent en lettonie depuis
des décennies aussi ils ne peuvent ni
voter ni exercer certaines professions
comme juges avocats ou fonctionnaires
alors pour certains députés cela
s'apparente à de la discrimination quand
une partie non négligeable de la
population est exclu de la vie politique
d'un pays ce n'est pas de la démocratie
la majorité d'entre eux sont nés ici ils
ont passé leur vie ici ils paient leurs
impôts et non pas d'autres terres qu'ici
en lettonie dans ce petit pays d'europe
après l'occupation soviétique la
question de l'identité est primordial
pour les lettons pour sept députés la
loyauté vis-à-vis du pays d'accueil est
une condition sinequanone pour obtenir
le droit de vote
j'ai peur surtout si l'on regarde ce
qu'il s'est passé entre la russie et
l'ukraine
certes les apatrides ne peuvent pas
voter c'est un droit politique pour
lequel ils sont limités mais je crois
que compte tenu de notre lourde histoire
nous devions le faire
c'est un choix politique très important
ceux qui veulent devenir citoyens et
être loyaux le peuvent ils pourront
ainsi voter aux élections
l'exemple ukrainien a ravivé la peur
d'une nouvelle emprise russe en 2012 les
autorités ont bloqué un projet de
référendum pour régulariser en masse les
minorités russophones en 2011
75% des lettons ont dit non un autre
référendum sur l'introduction de la
langue russe comme seconde langue
officielle
pour ce politologue ces craintes sont
légitimes
il faut dire que les apatrides ont
facilement les yeux rivés sur moscou ils
vivent ici mais vous savez ils regardent
la télévision russe
ils reçoivent les cinq chaînes les plus
populaires et souvent ces télévisions
sont anti lettonie anti ouest anti otan
voilà dans quel environnement ils vivent
et cela a une grande influence sur leur
envie de devenir les tongs pas là dit
mir lui n'a pas voulu devenir les tons
ouvriers dans l'armée aujourd'hui
retraité il habite dans une banlieue
éloignée de riga un ancien quartier
militaire russe et si le drapeau les
tongs flotte devant la maison il y a
aussi une raison particulière
c'est comme ça ici
la mairie nous demande de mettre le
drapeau quand on a des visiteurs alors
quand vous êtes des invités spéciaux gmi
drapeau pour vous vladimir et sa femme
sont arrivés il y à une quarantaine
d'années il possède aujourd'hui un
passeport de non citoyens
cela leur permet de voyager vers la
russie sans visa mais pas en europe pour
eux peu importe leur vie est ici loin de
la société lettone
j'ai de la nostalgie de l'époque
soviétique avant c'était bien on était
une grande région je pense que c'est de
la discrimination
les estoniens les lituaniens ils ont
tous donné la nationalité alors pour moi
c'est un principe je ne veux pas à
prendre le letton y passer des tests
mais je ne suis pas en colère je n'ai
rien contre les lettons c'est de la
politique
c'est contre les dirigeants que je pense
cela plus de vingt ans après son
indépendance
la lettonie n'a pas oublié ce demi
siècle d'occupation soviétique et même
s'ils sont plus de 143 milles à être
devenus les tons le statut des apatrides
et toujours aujourd'hui une source de
friction entre riga et moscou